bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce mardi 9 février première audience
du procès du sang contaminé devant la
cour de justice de la république les
ministres accusés s'expriment les
victimes les interpelle avec virulence
la cour impose aux médecins responsables
de la transfusion sanguine dont docteur
guerre état de venir témoigner
les avalanches en haute-savoie détruit
11 chalet près de chamonix ce deux morts
dont une enfant quatre personnes
disparues c'est un bilan provisoire les
chutes de neige continues dans les alpes
et l'est de la france
l'information judiciaire ouverte après
le saccage du ministère de
l'environnement par des agriculteurs les
élus verts en butte à des séries de
manifestations hostiles invitait le
journal madame dominique voynet
régularisation de 250 mille immigrés
clandestins annoncées par le
gouvernement italien s'est immigrés
avaient fait une demande de permis de
séjour avant la fin de 98 cinéma demain
mille et une pattes sur les écrans c'est
le dernier film de walt disney avec une
petite fourmi et sept mercenaires
la première audience du procès devant la
cour de justice de la république de
laurent fabius
edmond hervé et georgina dufoix s'est
achevée à 17 heures cette journée était
marquée par trois moments forts que nous
allons détailler les déclarations des
ministres
les interventions des victimes et la
décision de la cour d'obliger les
médecins responsables de la transfusion
sanguine à l'époque à comparaître
voici pour commencer le récit de la
journée avec le reportage de thierry
kurt et patrick desmulie et virgili ados
laurent fabius en homme seul qui entre
par une petite porte discrète l'unique
image de l'ancien premier ministre
aujourd'hui la caméra ne le verra pas
aux côtés de ses deux anciens collègues
passent à ses juges face à ses pairs 29
robe noire six magistrats 23 députés ou
sénateurs une cour impressionnante a dit
me tente
à l'extérieur les victimes rassemblées
sont très déterminés certaines exclus de
la procédure ont tout de même tenu à
être là on n'aura pas la parole on va
subir de l'an passé d excuser moi c'est
quand même un moment qui est difficile
pour nous parce que il n'y en a droit
d'avoir d'avocats n'y en a le droit de
dire ce qu'on a ce qu'on a à dire et on
va subir ils pourront dire les pires
manche en or est le droit de se taire
ceux dont la plainte a été retenue
attendez ce face à face avec les
ministres depuis dix ans mais sylvie
roui trop fatigué et retourner à
l'hôpital sans avoir pu témoigner et moi
mon état ne me permet pas de repartir de
revenir à faire
que quand on les taxe santé me le
permettra de revenir témoigner
le président de la cour a dit d'accord
mais mettra fabien président de l'as
poussan tu es ce que je pouvais revenir
arrivé voilà pas ou peu de curieux mais
un public très concerné au milieu
discret quelques militants socialistes
inquiète - savoir si les trois
spécialistes
blanchi
parce que
coupables à savoir dans quelle mesure le
rendre justice
lors des compressions dans le procès qui
n'a pas lieu au palais de justice mais
dans un centre de conférences pas de
l'arc de triomphe est prévu pour durer
trois semaines
le président de la cour de justice
monsieur christian le gunéhec s'est
adressé aux trois accusés en ces termes
la décision que nous allons rendre est
importante pour vous 3 vous êtes depuis
trop longtemps en état de comparution
permanente devant un autre tribunal sans
légitimité mais non sans pouvoir fin de
citation et monsieur le gunéhec désigne
est ainsi l'opinion publique
cet après midi les trois anciens
ministres ont entendu les déclarations
faites au juge de plusieurs des victimes
celles ci ont souvent dénoncé la
procédure et les ont désignés comme
coupables avec virulence aux propos
parfois repris à l'extérieur de la salle
du centre de conférences internationales
vous l'avez entendu où se tient donc la
cour de justice
reportage 2000 verdeilhan rémy
poissonnier pivot pic a été condamné
lors d'une transfusion sanguine à l'été
85 sa plainte en 84 ans fait partie des
sept qui ont été retenus par la cour de
justice de la république dans la salle
d'audience passe devant lui certains des
témoins qui vont être entendus comme le
professeur willy rozenbaum spécialiste
du sida simple témoin ce procès c'est un
statut qui vaut au pic n'a nommé pape
je suis victime d'un crime contre
l'humanité dit il puis l'homme se tourne
vers le procureur général qui a requis
par deux fois le non lieu
sa présence est une insulte aux victimes
lance-t-il à l'intention du magistrat
calmement il vos piques s'insurge contre
ce procès pour lui c'est une mascarade
cette cour est quand même un peu
bizarrement constitué quoi
on l'a bien vu dans la presse ces
derniers jours le président est pas très
intègre parce qu'il a fait sa carrière
politique
le procureur a déjà requis le non-lieu
c'est lui qui représente l'accusation
puisque a pas de partie civile
sûr qu'un juge d'où sont des
parlementaires donc pratiquement dès
ségo de ceux qui sont accusés
agnès cochin a perdu un fils
pharmacienne dit elle posément
j'ai été en relation avec le ministère
de la santé c'est un petit ministère où
l'information circule
puis le témoin s'emporte regarde les
trois ministres droit dans les yeux
pourquoi ces gens occupe-t-il toujours
des fonctions officielles
vous n'avez pas honte mais c'est vers
edmond hervé que madame cochin concentre
ses attaques
est-ce qu'ils avaient des consignes plus
haut je n'en sais rien mais la décision
venait de lui c'est lui qui a condamné
quatre ans ce matin les trois ministres
avaient pris très rapidement la parole
edmond hervé déterminer j'assume mon
action je démontrerai mon innocence
notre innocence et celle de nos
collaborateurs georgina dufoix
professoral ce moment et juste nous
devons nous expliquer il est normal que
nous répondions à ceux qui souffrent
laurent fabius très pondéré j'espère que
ce procès pourra établir que nous avons
réagi en conscience et comme nous le
devions je crois que les plaignants
ressentent une véritable douleur nous la
comprenons tous mais les explications
qui sont donnés par les prévenus ça ne
constitue pas la dénégation de cette
douleur c'est une volonté de leur
expliquer deux autres victimes devrait
être entendu dans les jours prochains
mais la majorité des témoins sont
désormais des scientifiques et des
conseillers ministériels nommés hiver
veilhan le dialogue est quasiment
impossible en tout cas très très
difficile après 15 ans d'errance
judiciaire on est probablement arrivé à
un point de non-retour les blessures du
côté des victimes sont probablement trop
grande pour qu'il y ait dialogue est
d'ailleurs cet après-midi les prévenus
se sont bien gardé de répondre aux
victimes ou de leur poser des questions
alors on se parlera probablement pas la
question est de savoir si lyon les trois
semaines de ce procès on va au moins
s'entendre alors il ya une expression de
monsieur le gunéhec qui préside donc
cette cour de justice
il a parlé d'un processus réel
en quoi est issu réalise dès ce matin
depuis ce matin tout cas la conséquence
de tout ça c'est une certaine
improvisation pour ne pas dire un
cafouillage par exemple faute de pouvoir
entendre d'autres témoins cet après midi
bien lourde ans a failli être levée à
16h30 on s'est repris on a décidé de
meubler l'après-midi rediffusant des
documents vidéos concernant des
documents relatifs aux années 85 86
alors vous l'avez dit le président
christian le gunéhec en ses distances
avec cette loi qui définit cette
juridiction exceptionnelle qu'il semble
lui-même maîtriser difficilement une
parle de lacunes de la loi de curiosité
de procédures impressionniste sur
réaliste des petites piques acerbes qui
vise le législateur députés et des
parlementaires des députés et des
sénateurs
autrement dit ceux qui siègent à ses
côtés alors une curiosité
supplémentaires comment se sont
comportés ses juges ses sénateurs ces
députés qui qui était pour la première
fois devenus des juges
écoutez j'allais dire très attentif très
attentifs aux propos à la fois des
politiques et des victimes mais aucune
question de leur côté n'a également été
posée il avait donc quitté l'assemblée
nationale et à l'assemblée nationale
c'est le premier vice président monsieur
raymond forni qui a présidé cette
après-midi la séance des questions au
gouvernement en l'absence donc de
laurent fabius
mais parmi les députés nombreux ont été
ceux qui ont réagi à l'ouverture de ce
procès reportage aux baptistes prédalles
et philippe lety
voilà petit problème de blocage de
l'image qui est à l'assemblée nationale
et auparavant nous allons voir ce qui a
été l'un des événements forts de ce
procès ouvertes ce matin devant la cour
de justice de la république à savoir
celui de la décision prise par les juges
c'est à dire trois magistrats
professionnels six sénateurs et six
députés d'ordonner la comparution de
témoins qui refusait de venir à priori
car ils sont mis en examen dans
l'instruction parallèle pour
empoisonnement conduite donc par une
autre juge ils devront donc venir de gré
ou de force mais ils ne seront pas
obligés de prêter serment a dit la cour
explications sur l'identité de ces
témoins avec olivier kauf cinq acteurs
du premier procès du sang contaminé vont
devoir comparaître de gré ou de force
devant la cour de justice de la
république
il y a 6 ans ils étaient accusés ou
témoins aujourd'hui la cour veut les
entendre il y a d'abord trois anciens du
cnts michel garretta le directeur de
l'époque
dans le premier procès il avait été
condamné à quatre ans de prison ferme
bahman habib sy lui était le numéro deux
du cnts en 93 il était simple témoin
quant à jean pierre allain il dirigeait
les recherches du centre
en appel il avait écopé de 4 ans de
prison dont deux avec sursis
aujourd'hui jean-pierre à l'invite à
cambridge en angleterre
vendredi il viendra devant la cour mais
son avocat n'apprécie pas la méthode
nous semble particulièrement déloyale
c'est de donner à ceux qui défendent
actuellement les politiques les
témoignages les dépositions de ceux qui
sont poursuivis en droit commun avec la
faculté de décomposer de disséquer de
commenter et d'attaquer ce qu'ils vont
dire en leur réservant pour beaucoup
plus tard un autre procès car ces trois
hommes n'ont pas fini avec la justice
ils sont mises en examen pour complicité
d'empoisonnement dans un autre volet
d'affaires un responsable administratif
que la cour de justice peut également
entendre est exactement dans le même cas
jacques roux ancien directeur général de
la santé condamné en 93 remis en examen
et donc dispensé de prêter serment
vous ne prêtez pas serment
vous pouvez y compris refusé vrai pour
dix ans je me présente
je je me donne aucune suite à cette
campagne âge et je refuse ne répond même
situation enfin pour claude vaisselle
berg un conseiller d'edmond hervé témoin
en 93 mise en examen de cuillé désormais
témoin forcé au procès de son ancien
supérieur
alors pour conclure cette information
concernant la cour de justice de la
république tentons maintenant de voir
quelles ont été les réactions des
députés présents à l'assemblée nationale
cet après midi le protocole est à
changer les circonstances
exceptionnelles cet après midi raymond
forni le premier vice président de
l'assemblée nationale présidé la séance
des questions pendant le procès du sang
contaminé
il remplace laurent fabius dans
l'hémicycle en plus de laurent fabius et
d'edmond hervé 12 députés sont absents
il siège en robe noire à la cour de
justice de la république
un procès a commencé et quelques députés
ils seront aussi témoin la quoi réjouir
tous les quelques éléments que je vais
apporter commencé mi la santé par deux
fois ses taux dans les couloirs une
certaine gêne masques et parfois par des
positions de principe
tous ces commentaires alors que
l'audience a commencé
ce serait déplacé en fait même à gauche
on tente de concilier solidarité
politique et exigence de justice
il servirait à rien que contester la
justice me faut plus 10 puisse
travailler travailler dans la sérénité
et surtout rechercher la vérité
il est normal que lorsqu'il y a des
responsabilités personnelles pénal comme
quiconque un élu un ministre un
président de la république d'ailleurs la
question est la même
soit soumis à la même loi que n'importe
quel citoyen à droite pas de position
unique non plus mais on s'efforce déjà
de tirer les leçons du procès je ne sais
pas ce que sont les responsabilités
à mon avis le vrai problème est celui du
dysfonctionnement de l'état qui
fonctionne très mal parce qu'il est trop
centralisée et que les responsabilités
sont diluées
au premier jour du procès on est loin
des polémiques de 1992 de la mise en
accusation de laurent fabius et de ses
ministres
aujourd'hui malgré le malaise on s'en
remettait plus tôt à la justice une
avalanche atteint aujourd'hui 11 chalet
au village du tour en haute savoie les
coûts les neiges d'antan celui les
habitations situées non loin de son mix
au dessus de l'argentière le bilan
premier soir serait de 2 morts et 4
personnes disparues didier guyot vous
êtes sur place
est ce que vous confirmez ce bilan et
pouvez-vous donner d'autres informations
sur ce qui s'est passé ou écouter le
bilan en effet n'est que provisoire
hélas pour l'instant on parle de deux
morts quatre cinq disparus chiffres
également provisoire car on ne sait pas
qui étaient là au moment de cette
avalanche qu'il y avait dans les chalets
qui également se promener sur les routes
des promeneurs peut-être en raquettes
étaient là au moment de l'avalanche en
gros 20 personnes auraient été dégagés
la personne donc survivante de serait
légèrement blessé alors bien sûr il faut
tenter d'imaginer ce qu'était cette
avalanche ces quelques c'est une de la
neige sur plus de 200 mètres qui a
dévalé donc dans la vallée sur un petit
hameau de montroc emportant sur son
passage au chalet ainsi que les uns tout
ce qu'il pouvait trouver sur sur son
passage
bien évidemment les conditions
météorologiques sont très très mauvais
sont excécrables pour les sauveteurs il
ya quelques 200 sauveteurs sur place des
gendarmes des guidons sonde on pèle mais
c'est très très compliqué voyez il loge
il fait nuit des projecteurs ont été
installés sur tout on a peur que
d'autres coulées de neige arrive
d'ailleurs par précaution des dizaines
de personnes ont été évacuées de leurs
maisons dans les hameaux tout proche
alors vous trouvez en ce moment à
chamonix que c'est très compliqué de
circuler dans cette région est-ce qu'il
faut recommander à tout le monde de
rester plutôt chez soi pour permettre
aux secours de
de se déployer bien évidemment écouter
tout le monde ici dit à toutes les
personnes qui habitent là de ne pas
sortir ce soir de ne surtout pas prendre
sa voiture si ce n'est pas nécessaire
beaucoup on a peur de nombreuses coulées
de neige surtout cet axe sur toute la
vallée de chamonix donc ce qui fait
qu'on risque d'avoir d'autres d'autres
accidents on ne peut pas purger pour
l'instant parce qu'il sait ni bien sûr
on ne peut pas les quais avec des
hélicoptères pour lancer de la dynamite
et enlever cette eau neige donc on sait
que là haut parce qu'il a tellement
neige qui tombe depuis quelques jours on
sait que d'autres coulées peuvent
arriver donc à sion en demande à tout le
monde d'être très très prudent et
surtout on sait dire combien c'est
dangereux les sauveteurs niveau là aussi
qu'avec la plus grande prudence sur
place et qui paie d'ailleurs d'un
matériel sophistiqué pour pouvoir être
opéré en cas d'avalanche
alors merci didier nous allons voir
maintenant avec agnès garder comment sur
les lieux ça s'est passé et les effets
de ces coulées de neige
deux avalanches que ce recours athènes
en début d'après-midi les hameaux du
tour et mon rock
14h30 première coulée de neige du haut
du glacis duper clos vos dix minutes
plus tard seconde à valence beaucoup
plus violente
j'ai défendu très fort très fort souffle
et on est d'apogéa jusqu'au parking
jusqu'au parking de l'hôtel
et puis on l'a vu les arbres des sympas
à tous parqués comme des allumettes et
puis après il ya un grand silence qui
sont ces choristes sont sur les lieux
dans une zone presque impraticable le
likoud peut pas décoller donc la montée
en puissance par l'hélico n'est pas
possible
ensuite la route qui donc qui permet
d'accéder au tour est bloquée par une
autre avalanche
donc pour l'instant c'est vrai comme on
est contraint de
d'acheminer l'ensemble des personnels
par voie terrestre à pied cette france
qui leur donnaient tous les moyens des
secours d'autant plus difficile à
organiser que des avalanches sont encore
à craindre dans les heures qui viennent
le plan rouge d'organisation de secours
était déclenché par la préfecture de
haute-savoie il s'agit d'abord de tenter
de retrouver des personnes portées
disparues peut être ensevelies et dans
ces cas de forte avalanche la technique
des secouristes et celle démontrée dans
le reportage qui suit avec les
commentaires patrice pollet la puissance
d'une avalanche
c'est ça ces images ont été tournées il
ya quelques semaines par un cinéaste
amateur en idole
maintenant la survie de ceux qui sont
ensevelis dépend de la rapidité des
secours les sondages commencent toujours
au pied de l'avalanche c'est à dire à
l'endroit où la neige la plus épaisse
organisé par vagues de 10 à 15 mètres on
sonde le manteau neigeux en remontant
vers le sommes
une technique qui a fait ses preuves et
sauvé de nombreuses vies depuis
plusieurs années les chiens l'avalanche
comme ce labrador donne une chance
supplémentaire à ceux qui sont en ce
qu'ils cherchent là c'est une personne
qui est enseveli sous la neige
il a des textes des odeurs qui sont très
légères qui émane de notre corps d'une
façon volatiles qui traverse le manteau
neigeux et ce sont ses seuls l'odeur là
qui intéresse le chien par opposition
aux odeurs que l'on laisse en marchant
sur la neige
à chaque fois c'est une course contre la
montre
chaque minute compte les victimes
ensevelies sous plusieurs mètres de
neige sont soumises à de très fortes
pressions et à de basses températures
elles risquent l'asphyxient et
l'hypothermie
il faut fermer en direct avec monsieur
michel charles elle maire de chamonix ce
monsieur le maire bonsoir est ce que
vous pourriez nous faire le point sur
l'organisation des secours et puis les
risques peut-être à venir pour la soirée
alors l'organisation des secours ils
sont bien sûr sous le commandement du
pghm de chamonix avec le sdiss de la
haute-savoie lé sens départemental
d'incendié et de secours
il est environ 200 personnes sur les
lieux quels sont les risques aux
problèmes que nous avons les risques
continuent puisque avec les hauteurs de
neige qu'il y a eu plus d'un mètre 80
en quatre jours tous les autres couloirs
d'avalanche de la vallée sont
aujourd'hui à risque et le risque c'est
les sauveteurs bien sûr qu'ils se
prennent eux mêmes dans une une autre
avalanche qui risquent de tomber
vous craignez que d'autres personnes
isolées dans certains chalets ne soient
elles aussi prisonnière des avalanches
et de la neige
normalement le maximum de précautions a
été pris toutes les routes où il ya un
risque aussi minime soit il en était
fermé on a répertorié tous les chalets
qui sont à proximité d'un éventuel d'une
éventuelle avalanche et toutes ces
personnes ont été évacuées sont
recentrés d'un cité scolaire
merci monsieur charles ix en suisse et
dans toute l'europe occidentale avec de
froid accompagnée de neige et de verglas
de graves conséquences dans l'est de la
france le mauvais temps provoque de
graves perturbations de circulation
s'est notamment qu'à 1 mulhouse et
besançon également des coupures de
courant
le parquet de paris a ouvert une
information judiciaire pour dégradations
de biens publics et violences en réunion
après le saccage hier du ministère de
l'environnement et d'une partie des
locaux de l'ena par les agriculteurs cet
après midi à l'assemblée nationale le
premier ministre a vivement condamné ces
actes graves et inadmissibles
ces actes sont d'autant moins admissible
et ils ne seront d'ailleurs à l'avenir
pas tolérer que la voie du dialogue a
toujours été ouverte et reste ouvert
avec les représentants légitimes du
monde agricole
nous avons souvent ici même et parfois
et souvent à votre demande
parler des problèmes d'insécurité et de
violence urbaine pensons donc à l'
exemple déplorable qui a été donné hier
à des jeunes que l'on invite par
ailleurs à respecter la loi commune le
ministre de l'intérieur a indiqué qu'une
enquête était en cours concernant aussi
des dysfonctionnements en matière de
sécurité autour des bâtiments publics et
quinze agriculteurs ont été déférés
devant les autorités judiciaires cet
après midi au total plus de 300
personnes avaient été arrêtées après ces
incidents
enquête yann fronty
en se rendant ce matin à matignon luc
guyau le savez la réunion devait avoir
pour thème l'agriculture française mais
il allait se faire rappeler à l'ordre
visiblement le message a été compris je
réaffirme le vent vous que le président
de la fnsea des a's approuve ce genre
d'actions qui ne servent ni à cause du
syndicalisme ni la cause de
l'agriculture image symbole de cette
violence mal contenue le bureau de
dominique voynet mise à sac hier par une
centaine d'agriculteurs très remonté
mobilier retourner dossier dispersé au
lendemain de cette action spectaculaire
les organisateurs justifient de manière
à peine voilée
ces débordements et la fnsea nous a dit
le 19 janvier fait monter la pression
vous avez une deadline c'est le 22
février à bruxelles
allez-y évidemment quand on dit aux gens
allez-y finalement il ya peut-être des
gens qui exagèrent sur six possibles
négocié la réforme de la pac tout en
défendant les intérêts d'une partie de
sa base les céréaliers ceux là mêmes qui
manifestent et hier la position est
difficile à tenir pour la fnsea
et c'est vrai que les céréaliers
actuellement son temps sont tentés
peut-être entre guillemets de faire
sécession parce que c'est eux qui sont
dans le collimateur parce que c'est eux
qui ont plus à perdre dans la politique
agricole commune car les revenus des
céréaliers sont très dépendants des
aides européennes
ainsi en 1996 chaque exploitation
agricole d'île de france a reçu en
moyenne 260 mille francs pour mémoire en
1992 lors de la première réforme de la
pac la fnsea avait été débordé par ces
mêmes céréaliers regroupés au sein de la
coordination rurale
cette année le syndicat compte mieux
canaliser le mécontentement mais
l'épisode d'hier prouve que la tâche
s'annonce difficile
alors les agriculteurs hier mais aussi
les chasseurs les salariés syndiqués cgt
du nucléaire depuis plusieurs semaines
les élus écologistes ont manifestement
des cibles privilégiées explication
alban nicosie philippe du mail c'est
sans doute la saison qui veut cela la
chasse aux écologistes bat son plein
trois semaines de campagne et les
incidents sont déjà légion image symbole
bien sûr daniel cohn bendit malmené
devant l' usine de la cogema la hague et
le même soir bloqué devant un café de
cherbourg
il doit annuler sa réunion publique est
rentré à paris sous protection policière
dans le vaucluse
aso chasseurs et agriculteurs
envahissent un de ses meetings au delà
de cohn-bendit le ressentiment se porte
sur dominique voynet
quelle que soit la région c'est quand
même notre ministre de tutelle
on l'a dit souvent c'est un peu comme si
j'étais repris la justice était garde
des sceaux nous avons le ministre
d'achat ce qui s'affiche en tee shirt
comment voulez vous que l'on débouche
sur ces problèmes-là chasseurs mais
aussi agriculteur en face les crs en
baie de somme
marie-anne isler béguin numéro deux de
la liste des verts et ce jour-là
copieusement injurié enfin hier la
descente d'un commando d'agriculteurs au
ministère de l'environnement
c'est absolument inconcevable que même
on puisse entrer dans son propre bureau
tout mettre à sac enfin j'imagine très
mal qu'on puisse entrer comme ça dans le
bureau de monsieur chevènement par
exemple dans les régions comme ici en
aquitaine les plainte pour menaces
verbales quelquefois physique se
multiplient une rencontre entre verts et
délégués des chasseurs est prévue le 22
février
pourra-t-elle désamorcer le malaise ce
n'est pas sûr
les chasseurs reproche à dominique
voynet d'être davantage militante que
ministre dominique bonnet bonsoir tout
ça notre confrère le monde parle de la
haine du verre est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que vous suscitez la haine
je suscite l'agacement d'un certain
nombre de lobbies intérêts privés qui
sont malmenés c'est vrai par les
questions 9 et les propositions
nouvelles elles aussi des verts je crois
que le vent de fraîcheur que nous
faisons souffler dans la vie politique
française n'est pas acceptée avec
reconnaissance ou bienveillance par tous
ces intérêts privés qui se rebiffe
durement ce soir vous dites ça avec un
petit sourire mais manifestement vous
n'êtes pas très soutenue par vos
camarades socialistes
vous êtes un peu isolé face à tout un
tas de gens qui l'est qui viennent chez
vous comment vous jugez ça alors je
crois que sur un point au moins les
choses sont claires
le premier ministre a condamné façon
très claire très ferme les actes
inqualifiables des jours derniers il
l'avait fait au moment où dany
cohn-bendit avait été empêchée de
manifestations et de débats publics à
log
je ne sens pas dans la majorité
plurielle de réticences face à cette
diversité à cette pluralité des débats
c'est des dirigeants socialistes
chasseurs qui se vouent soutiennent pas
beaucoup comme un oui mais ça c'est
normal on a un différend sur un dossier
c'est normal c'est passé pas très grave
non ce qui me paraît plus grave c'est
c'est ce qui s'est passé au ministère ya
pas parce que c'est dans mon bureau
c'est pas très grave
et d'ailleurs les dégâts visuels ne sont
pas les plus importants ce qui est le
plus grave ce sont les insultes
les insultes sexistes les insultes
racistes les menaces physiques qui ont
été exercés à l'égard de fonctionnaires
qui sont là pour faire leur travail et
qui ont été quand même très très
durement déstabilisé sur un mot voudrais
poser pour en sélectionner c'était un
homme qui était musicien émises de
l'environnement ce soit serait pas
pareil disons c'est un phénomène
aggravant être une femme verte jeune et
avoir son franc parler c'est
manifestement trop pour un certain
nombre d'intérêts dans la société
française mais est ce que vous faites la
part aussi de la revendication est à
dire du droit à manifester du
militantisme des des agriculteurs alors
salué les actes qu'il commette pas
résidents par quoi je crois nécessaire
aussi de dire qu'un certain nombre de
manifestants prennent en otage une bonne
partie des paysans français qui n'ont
pas forcément le même intérêt que le
céréaliers d'île de france et qui ont du
mal à faire entendre leur voix dans ce
concert moi je je constate que les
paysans du jura qui ont des primes jeu
bien inférieur pour faire une
agriculture de qualité avec des produits
de qualité avec des emplois qui sont
maintenus dans des zones difficiles
territoire ne manifestaient pas ne casse
pas j'avais vu d'enfants parmi les
manifestants
hier des paysans qui bénéficie de plus
d'un million de francs de primes par
huit sur les laiteries villégier les
céréales dans pense qu'il ya une
connotation politique derrière tout ça
disons que les bénéficiaires privilégié
de la pac n'entendent pas renoncer à
leurs privilèges
moi j'ai des choses qui me paraissent
évidentes et qu'il éprouve aucune
culture dire devant vous le fait que 80
% des primes de la pac à ya 20% des
paysans le fait qu'il y ait des
inégalités aussi insensé au sein même du
monde agricole avec d'un côté des petits
paysans qui croule sous les charges les
difficultés et de l'autre des casseurs
mais il est très lent d'otages que ça me
parait collègue jean glavany pour qu'ils
essayent d'y remédier mais ça paraît
évident c'est un des enjeux de la
réforme de la pac
le fait qu'on attribue les primes aussi
élevé sans aucune condition de bonnes
pratiques environnementales sans aucune
attention au contenu en emplois des
activités c'est quelque chose qui ne
pourra pas durer et seulement les
bénéficiaires de la pac d'aujourd'hui le
savent bien il faudra partager de façon
plus juste vous où les verts où daniel
cohn bendit vous allez pouvoir faire une
campagne européenne ça continue comme ça
pourrais jamais sortir sans susciter des
bagarres des insultes des orions d'une
certaine façon moi je crois je croyais
vraiment toujours beaucoup au dialogue à
la concertation au ministère n'était pas
un blockhaus il était ouvert parce que
très régulièrement les syndicats les
intérêts qui sont présents ca de la
société sont reçus dans ce ministre
moi je le dis très clairement je ne fais
pas l'amalgamé entre les quelques
dizaines de casseurs qui sont venus
effectivement se payer la tête d'une
ministre en espérant une fois de plus
l'impunité et puis la grande majorité
des paysans qui sont très sensibles à
notre soif de dialogue et qui ont envie
qu'on continue cette discussion dans
l'intérêt et campagnes françaises
satisfaction votre loi sur l'aménagement
du territoire était votée en première
lecture
vous pensez qu'elle sera votée
définitivement avant la fin de l'année
et je le souhaite il faut qu'elles le
soient avant l'été pour que nous
puissions à mettre en place la
négociation des contrats de plan état
région qui est aussi fondamental pour
l'avenir non seulement des zones rurales
mais aussi des quartiers des villes je
crois que les élus se prépare cette
discussion qui va être passionnante
merci
petite mobilisation pour la journée
d'action des enseignants d'ile-de-france
qui protestent contre les réformes en
cours de monsieur allègre il y avait
d'autres grèves d'autres manifestations
dans l'éducation en france aujourd'hui
en dehors de paris et notamment dans les
vosges à vannes et à lorient dans
l'agglomération lyonnaise le trafic des
autobus était assuré à 50% en raison
d'un mouvement lancé par les chauffeurs
qui protestent contre l'insécurité
pour la même raison il n'y avait pas de
transports en commun il n'y a pas de
transports en commun à mulhouse et à
nîmes
et puis deux décisions judiciaires
concernent deux lycéens âgés tous les
deux de 18 ans ils ont été condamnés
l'un à versailles pour avoir tenté
d'étrangler son professeur à quatre mois
de prison dont trois avec sursis et
l'autre à maubeuge à 12 mois de prison
dont huit avec sursis pour avoir frappé
d'un coup de poing au visage
un professeur les deux lycéens ont été
incarcérés en jordanie au lendemain des
funérailles du roi hussein une cérémonie
traditionnelle va maintenant durée de
trois jours trois journées sans aucun
protocole ni mesures de sécurité le roi
abdallah ii et sa famille vont recevoir
l'hommage de jordaniens
quel que soit leur rang ou leur origine
reportage à la manne de nos envoyés
spéciaux philippe rochot et patrick voit
les tribus bédouines en abaya noire
brodée d'or et en keffieh rouge avait
remplacé ce matin les chefs d'état
étrangers ou les rois du monde arabe les
condoléances à la famille royale vont
durer trois jours au palais ragga dan
peu trop tôt comme n'importe quel
citoyen peut venir saluer le roi et ses
frères cette tradition montre à quel
point la famille royale est proche de la
société
ceux qui saluent le souverain son frère
fait salle où le prince héritier ramsey
se sont ainsi impliqués dans le pouvoir
on n'a jamais eu avec le roi hussein des
rapports de gouvernants et gouvernés
nous avons toujours eu des rapports de
famille unie pour les femmes la
cérémonie des condoléances se déroule au
palais zaramella c'est plutôt la haute
société qui vient saluer les rênes et
les princesses
en jordanie une femme peut être ministre
ou sénateur les pousses du roi hussein
la reine nour a placé à ses côtés la
princesse basma la soeur du roi hussein
qui avait donné sa moelle épinière pour
le sauver elles se disent inconsolable
comme le sont les jordanienne qui
remercie le roi défunt
il a fait beaucoup pour la femme la
première dame
par contre toutes les femmes arabes
c'est une femme libre qui peut
travailler tout est à côté des hommes
qui est considéré qui a toutes tous les
droits presque à la sortie du palais les
jordanienne voulaient espérer que la
nouvelle reine rania allait aussi les
aider elle a commencé à travailler dès
les deux villes quand elle est mariée
avec la le prince quand il était prince
les principes de la paix elle avait
l'habitude de faire beaucoup de choses
ses condoléances interviennent le jour
du 22e anniversaire de la mort de la
reine alia tué dans un accident
d'hélicoptère c'était la troisième
épouse du roi hussein
elle avait eu un rôle essentiel dans sa
vie comme l'aura sans doute la reine
rania
les pousses du nouveau roi abdallah et
ce nouveau roi assuré bagdad de sa
volonté de développer les relations
irako jordanienne et avant de quitter la
jordanie le président bill clinton s'est
entretenu en tête à tête avec le
président syrien monsieur hafez al assad
en israël le premier ministre benjamin
netanyahu a promis un nouvel accord de
paix avant l'an 2000 avec le liban et la
syrie
mais il n'a pas précisé les conditions
de cet accord et puis à gaza un haut
responsable palestinien a affirmé que la
direction palestinienne envisageait un
report de quelques semaines pour la
proclamation d'un état palestinien
proclamation prévue par yasser arafat le
4 mai prochain en france à rambouillet
dans les yvelines les deux coprésidents
de la conférence de paix sur le kosovo
l'anglais robin cook et le français
hubert védrine
on rencontrait les négociateurs serbes
et kosovars officiellement messieurs
cook et védrine ont délivré un message
de fermeté mais les discussions sont
qualifiés par les négociateurs que vous
voyez de constructives mais difficile
aux états unis à washington les
sénateurs américains commencent ce soir
leurs délibérations avant de se
prononcer sur la destitution du
président bill clinton le pronostic est
certain monsieur clinton ne sera pas
destitué la majorité des deux tiers des
sénateurs soit 67 sur 100 ne peut être
atteinte
on s'attend donc à une sorte de
condamnation sous la forme d'un blâme
plus ou moins sévèrement rédigé en
italie le gouvernement a pris un décret
pour une régularisation éventuel
d'environ 250 mille immigrés clandestins
ces personnes avaient fait une
demande de permis de séjour avant la fin
de 98 ils devront répondre à différents
critères notamment un travail un
logement et un casier judiciaire vierge
explications de notre correspondant
alain de chalvron bonne nouvelle pour
tous ces émigrés en italie qui en
novembre et décembre derniers avaient
fait des heures et des heures de queue
dans l'espoir d'être régularisés ils
étaient 300 8000 à s'être ainsi rue et
dans les commissariats
trois cent mille pour trente mille
cartes de séjour promise 38000 heureux
270000 désespéré plongée désormais dans
une illégalité déclaré coup de théâtre
ce matin le ministre de l'intérieur rosa
russo iervolino annonce que la
quasi-totalité 250000 sera régularisée
tous ceux qui répondent aux critères
avoir un logement un travail un casier
judiciaire vierge et est rentré en
italie avant le 27 mars dernier
malgré l'arrivée quasi quotidienne de
centaines de clandestins l'italie n'a
que un million et demi d'immigrés sur
son sol 2,6 pour cent de la population
active contre une moyenne européenne de
5% de plus avec un des taux de fécondité
les plus bas d'europe
sa population paie ce trait s'il n'y
avait les migrations même la droite en
convient l'immigration en italie ce
n'est pas une question comme en france
parce que et les problèmes n'est pas
explosif forme en france les syndicats
en conviennent aussi en dépit d'un taux
de chômage maintenant supérieur à la
france
nous sommes pour la régularisation de
ceux qui sont en état dit mais à une
condition il faut qu'ils puissent être
absorbées par le marché du travail
et c'est précisément la contrepartie de
la mesure de régularisation adopté
aujourd'hui ceux qui ne répondent pas
aux critères devraient eux être
impitoyablement expulsé
ce soir à strasbourg le chancelier
allemand monsieur gerhard schröder
rejoint pour dîner le président chirac
le voici ensemble on m'annonce contours
de la table peut-être d'un plat alsacien
ils seront surtout question
il sera surtout question de l'agenda
2000 et du financement de l'union
européenne
pour l'instant on s'embrasse les actions
d'air france mise sur le marché avec
l'ouverture d'une privatisation
partielle du capital seront vendus 91
francs 83 aux particuliers l'ouverture
du capital d'air france devrait
rapporter 4 milliards de francs soit 610
millions d'euros à l'état du cinéma
demain sur les écrans mille et une pâtes
derrière dernière production de walt
disney avec une colonie de fourmis des
sauterelles et une princesse prénommée
attaque le tout en animation numérique
voyez le reportage de nicole cornu
langlois et nathalie gallet pour le
fruit laborieuse joyeuse le bonheur
serait vraiment dans le prix s'il n'y
avait dans rible son trail belliqueuse
pour les piller chaque annéé même rituel
ils viennent qu'il mangeait pas c'est le
sens de notre vie
un an sens mais tu es notre avis
culpabiliser milliers tilt fourmis
téméraire part pour la ville cherchait
des mercenaires capable de défendre sa
colonie ils découvrent d'eugenio
saltimbanques
100 des semis relance dangereux au moins
leurs écuries
les insectes tellement facétieux et
attachant que le réalisateur qui les a
créées a du mal à s'en séparer les
spectateurs savent que c'est un
divertissement
il n'existe mais grâce à l'utilisation
d'une image réalise ce monde magique
devient parfaitement crédible le public
se dit je sais que cela n'existe pas
mais ça a l'air tellement vrai accroc
majeur pour les dames four messieurs
quand vous allez les centrales vont
débarquer dans l'arène époustouflant de
virtuosité ce dessin animé est d'abord
basé sur une solide documentation
notamment grâce au film français
microcosmos en plus des prouesses
technologiques 60 animateurs repenser
chaque séquence pour que tous les
insectes soit attrayant possède un vrai
caractère et beaucoup d'humour c'est un
peu plus bas
ce qui est certain c'est qu'après avoir
vu ses mille et une pâtes personne
n'osera l'été prochain écraser un
insecte ou déranger une fourmilière et
regarder ça c'est très étonnant c'est
demain sur les écrans
je vous rappelle deux informations à la
fin de cette édition nous avons
développé dans ce journal tout d'abord
concernant l'ouverture du procès devant
la cour de justice république pour ses
du sang contaminé
devant les trois ministres laurent
fabius georgina dufoix edmond hervé la
cour de justice a décidé d'entendre et
de faire venir de gré ou de force les
témoins du monde médical ils sont
entendus dès vendredi
et puis avalanche d avalanche d
succession d'avalanches dans la vallée
de chamonix dans cette région le tour et
mon rock il y aurait pour l'instant
c'est un bilan provisoire deux morts et
quatre disparus le plan rouge a été
décrétée par la préfecture de haute
savoie
et puis on a plus aussi qu à courchevel
il ya un skieur qui est allé faire du
hors piste
il est disparu dans une avalanche et les
secours qui étaient partis ont failli
être emportés aussi par une nouvelle
coulée de neige donc fait attention on
joue pas les aventuriers dans un instant
la météo avec sophie davant qui
reviendra bien évidemment sur cette
actualité très neigeuse est très
dangereuse
à 23h20 ce sera place de la république
avec gilles tedder yamina benguigui et
le thème c'est des exclus de la santé
laurence ostolaza vous présentera
dernier journal à zéro heure 25 suivi du
cercle de philippe lefait et demain à
7h50 françoise laborde dans les 4
vérités recevra justement le président
de la fnsea
monsieur luc guyau à propos des du
saccage du vestiaire l'environnement
hier à 13 heures votre vraie carole
gaessler et rachid arhab à demain 20
heures dont soir merci